hey guys how's it going welcome to Jay
like some Justine I'm glad that I
introduced myself every single time for
you just in case you forget so this week
for videos the only videos that I could
find on youtube the people we're talking
about are watching is Miley Cyrus
humping on the VMA stage so I decided
I'm gonna make these videos that we
feature today some very special kitty
videos now there are so many cat videos
on the internet but there are three cats
they're my absolute favorite little bub
Hamilton the mustache cat and princess
monster truck and also this cat video
that I found is just so freaking cute
it's a cat caught rummaging and he's
like he's all like and then when he gets
caught he's all like
he now on to tech and gaming I have been
obsessed with the game dots in my last
video i posted i forgot to show you guys
my high score so here they are hopefully
i won't forget to post them this time
also the new call of duty black ops 2
apocalypse dlc was launched last week
which has two new maps pod and frost
the other two maps of reskin from
previous versions of called duty we have
take off which is from the first strike
black ops 1 dlc stadium
and dig which is courtyard from World
War
so now for the beauty style whatever I
don't actually have anything for you but
i did buy my first gun you can talk
about your face mask editor's note here
on the face mask we didn't realize that
it was for men my face hurts so bad
burning read the packaging ladies and
gentlemen and before we bought her face
masks we also went to the gun store are
always excited to see us right right
probably not I'm sneak shooting cuz I
don't want to get in trouble okay are
you kidding me we got to do zombie yes
that's okay yes concrete safety is off
I'm aiming for the movie I did I hit the
I know that's all for this episode of
idea likes hope you guys enjoyed it I'm
gonna go shoot my gun and put a face
mask on